listos para hablar sobre un posible
intercambio de prisioneros tras la
condena de nueve años en rusia de la
estrella del baloncesto estadounidense
brittney griner así lo anunciaron el
ministro de exteriores ruso serguéi
lávrov y el portavoz del kremlin quien
criticó la forma como eeuu ha manejado
las relaciones diplomáticas entre los
dos países
estamos listos para discutir este tema
pero solo dentro del marco del canal que
acordaron los presidentes putin y bailén
discutimos incluso algunos detalles de
los intercambios de prisioneros a través
de la prensa esos intercambios nunca se
llevarán a cabo los estadounidenses ya
cometieron ese error de repente
decidieron usar la diplomacia del
megáfono para resolver estos problemas
no es así como se resuelve así que no
daremos ningún comentario y está aquí
mis redes
el secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken dijo que a pesar de estar en
contra de la condena de greiner su país
sigue abierto al diálogo presentamos
como saben una propuesta sustancial para
que rusia se comprometa con nosotros y
lo que el ministro de asuntos exteriores
lávrov ha dicho esta mañana y ha
manifestado públicamente es que están
dispuestos a comprometerse a través de
los canales que hemos establecido para
hacer precisamente eso
el intercambio incluiría a la
basquetbolista y álex marín powell han
condenado por espionaje por víctor bout
un traficante de armas ruso en abrir los
dos países ya habían organizado un canje
de prisioneros entre el ex martín trevor
read y el piloto ruso konstantín
yaroshenko